what's up everybody its charlie today
we're gonna be talking about the
avengers illuminati the avengers were
supposed to be different than she
anybody remember when I carried a newt
through a wormhole no it's never come
save New York never heard that
recall that a hostile alien army came
charging through a hole in space we're
seeing a three hundred feet below it
worthy Avengers we can bust arms to us
all the live long day but that up there
that's that's same game how are you guys
planning on beating that so recently at
a Marvel press conference for Doctor
Strange Kevin Feige was being asked
about the future of Doctor Strange in
the Marvel Universe naturally we expect
him to appear in Avengers when asked a
follow-up question about the Illuminati
specifically Kevin Feige responded
what's fun about the Illuminati is
seeing certain characters interact with
certain other characters I don't know
about that particular storyline but some
of those characters will be synced
together on screen in the next Avengers
talking about infinity war so one what
he's talking about is is they're not
intending on doing a specific illuminati
comic book story in the way that
avengers movies like age of ultron or
infinity war aren't exact carbon copies
of the comic book stories so what he's
talking about is their own version of
the illuminati the most powerful
characters in the Marvel Universe coming
together to solve problems
the term Illuminati implies that it's a
secret society influencing things from
the shadows marvel's original illuminati
in the comics was Namor Tony Stark Reed
Richards Black Bolt Doctor Strange and
Professor X already you see that there
are a couple characters that Marvel
doesn't have access to like Professor X
they haven't done Namor in the movies
yet they can't do Reed Richards and they
haven't done Black Bolt yet so what
happened is is Brian Michael Bendis is
the comic book writer credited with
doing a lot of Illuminati stuff they
actually wrote into the continuity that
Marvel's Illuminati the six-member
secret society when
to both the peoples of the Kree and the
scrolls and said not to involve earth in
their war but just theoretically imagine
like somebody starts a war in the
guardians of the galaxy movie two big
races like the Kree in somebody else
like the Nova Corps imagine the most
powerful Marvel characters getting
together visiting them in saying do not
bring your conflict to earth or else
there will be consequences so in the
comics Iron Man has this idea you know
whereby after a great conflict ravages
the earth during this crease goal war he
says had we worked together you know
talking to all these other big
characters like Black Bolt Namor we
could have used information that we had
to prevent all this damage so the
Illuminati form and become this super
Avengers group like imagine problems ten
times worse more dire than what we've
seen in the Avengers movies so far like
Thanos comes to earth the illuminati
would be the ones to try and stop him
the regular Avengers would not be enough
and currently in the movies the Avengers
roster has been shattered so the most
likely candidates right now for the MCU
Illuminati would be of course Doctor
Strange black panther vision Iron Man
Thor
maybe Captain America if he can come to
terms with Iron Man and then eventually
maybe Nick Fury and Captain Marvel but
the thing is is that I think we'll see
more Illuminati level characters
introduced to the movies soon right now
we don't have that many so you kind of
have to go with the most powerful
versions of the characters they've
already done and talk about timely we're
getting ready for Infinity Ward Thanos
is assembling the Infinity Gauntlet it
was a comic book arc just called Marvel
infinity by Jonathan Hickman a couple
years ago where the Illuminati vote to
use the infinity gems that they have in
their possession to save the earth
Earth's most brilliant heroes the
Illuminati had convened to find a
solution and each of them wears an
implant to warn of new and currents to
prevent their first incursion they turn
to the near omnipotent infinity gems
the Illuminati succeeded but the gems
were lost so the idea is is based on the
trailers we've seen in dr. strange where
they talk about defending the earth from
mystical threats like they say The
Avengers protect the world from physical
threats we like the the Masters of the
mystic arts protect the earth from more
mystical threats so the idea is is that
some problem comes along via Thanos
infinity gems or even Dormammu in the
future that creates the need for an
Illuminati style group to form that goes
way beyond what the Avengers would
normally do but Doctor Strange is really
the key to that so we'll get our first
teasers for that during infinity war
when we see Iron Man's historical
paranoia like wanting to wrap the earth
in a shell of armor in dr. Strange's
knowledge of what really is out there
like you've seen physical threats you've
seen Ultron you've seen Chitauri but you
have not seen the things I have seen in
other dimensions it gets way worse than
that us in the Infinity Gauntlet so it
is gonna be amazing watching Doctor
Strange make Tony Stark pee his pants at
the thought of what else is out there
you know what's so amazing is you well
know about the comics is there so many
arenas to play with there's so many
characters to play with and every time
we introduce a new one to our Cinematic
Universe
that's just another storytelling tool in
the toolbox and of course dr. Stephen
strange himself that power base but the
whole notion of sorcerers now can can
expand into our movies and the notion of
parallel dimensions and alternate
realities and the multiverse is
something that we're very excited to
explore let me know in the comments
though who would you want to be in the
movie version of the Illuminati the most
powerful characters not all of them have
to be heroes Namor in the comics is a
member of the Illuminati but he's one of
those characters who has a relatively
fluid alignment but just remember that
any movie version of the Illuminati that
they do would be slightly different from
the comics just based on the characters
that they have available but I totally
think that at some point in the future
Marvel will come to terms with Fox and
they'll be able to share characters ala
Professor X
Menotti so hopefully by that time we'll
also see a recast version of Wolverine
that will be able to wear the yellow
costume but yet height there's a whole
bunch of other stuff happening this
weekend so be sure to subscribe to get
it I'll be doing more Doctor Strange
really soon I'll be doing a Walking Dead
negan video before Episode one drops
like final death predictions and there's
some really cool Game of Thrones
that I'm gonna be posting next there's
some really cool mind-blowing season 7
stuff happening new outro just a little
bit different while you guys wait for
that next video to post you can click up
top for the guardians of the galaxy
trailer again and you can click below
for the Logan red band trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
there are two types of beings in the
universe